Gleich wollen wir sprechen über den internationalen Top-Fußball in Europa, im Fußball der Männer. Vorher habe ich aber noch eine wichtige Mitteilung an euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Denn unsere Bankverbindung wird sich ändern, irgendwann ab dem 19. März. Das ist extrem ätzend für uns, ist auch nicht unsere Entscheidung, denn wir werden damit sicherlich Daueraufträge verlieren von Leuten von euch, die einen Dauerauftrag abgeschlossen haben. Deswegen bitte ich euch sehr, sehr herzlich, bitte geht auf rasenfunk.de und im Menü rechts oben, da könnt ihr euch registrieren für den Rasenfunk-Supporters Club. Das bedeutet erst mal nur, dass wir eine E-Mail-Adresse von euch bekommen und ihr auf dem Mail-Verteiler aller Rasenfunk-SupporterInnen landet. Keine Angst, gibt's kein Spam. Ein bis zwei Mails pro Jahr ist aktuell so der Schnitt. Und eben jetzt werdet ihr irgendwann ab dem 19. März eine Mail erhalten mit der neuen Bankverbindung. Und dann haben wir ein relativ enges Zeitfenster, in dem ihr dann bitte eure Daueraufträge ändert. Und dann hoffen wir, dass wir über diese Umstellung ganz gut hinwegkommen. Wir hatten das ja schon mal, als wir die GmbH gegründet haben, neue Bankverbindungen, da sind uns so 15 bis 20 Prozent des Supports ist uns da verloren gegangen. Das hat wehgetan. Deswegen, bitte registriert euch und bitte habt's auf dem Schirm. Ab 19. März wird sich das ändern. Jetzt geht's aber los mit der regulären Folge. Wir sprechen mit Daniel Zander, Uli Hebel, Alex Treuker und Mallorca. Abfahrt. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Die Herren, schön, dass ihr da seid. Hi. Es wird mir zugenehmigt. Hier sind echte Podcast-Profis am Tag. Wir müssen gleich reingehen. Alex, es wird jetzt sein Thema, aber es wird unser aller Thema. War das gestern ein Double Touch bei Atletico Madrid im Elfmeterschießen gegen Real Madrid? Ich habe es gelesen. Ich habe ausgemacht, weil ich mir gedacht habe, na gut, es wird jetzt Real Madrid irgendwann in der Verlängerung gewinnen. Das möchte ich nicht sehen. Grüße an Nils, es tut mir leid, aber ich habe es zu oft gesehen und habe es dann beim Zähneputzen im Kickerticker gelesen. Und da stand einfach nur drin AVR-Check, Doppelberührung. Da dachte ich mir, oh je, er ist ausgerutscht. Und meine Güte, ja, das kann passieren. Und dann habe ich irgendwann später, ich gebe zu nachts, dann die Bilder dazu gesehen. Ich sehe die Berührung nicht. Alex, du bist natürlich völlig unbiased bei diesem Thema. Siehst du die Doppelberührung?
Es ist jetzt natürlich eine größere Sache, ein größeres Thema. Kontext ist natürlich die Kultur und Fluchkultur in den verschiedenen Ländern. Also wenn wir Ulli hier haben in England, fuck you, fuck off, glaube ich vor allem fuck off, sagen die Spieler ständig so vor sich hin und brabbeln zum Gegner.
Kommt darauf an, in welchem Teil Englands.
Wahrscheinlich, aber da ist es einfach normal. Stell dir vor, da gäbe es immer rot, dann würde kein Spiel zu Ende gespielt werden. In Spanien ist die Fluchkultur auch sehr ausgeprägt, dass man ständig Jijo de Puta und so sagt auch vor sich hin, hundertmal beim Spielfeld, das wird da nicht immer mit geahndet, weil es einfach zu Kultur gehört, die einfach sehr derbe ist. Gleichzeitig solltest du es natürlich nicht dem Schiedsrichter ins Gesicht sagen und das hat eben Correa gemacht, also der den ganz klar beleidigt auch mit drei Sachen am Stück. Also es war nicht nur nicht nur Jijo de Puta, sondern mehr, wenn man es aber dann jetzt auf Deutschland anwendet und das hast du ja gerade gemacht, Max, ist es unvorstellbar, dass du zum Schiedsrichter F dich du hu... so und sagen würdest. Das ist natürlich, das wäre ein Monsterskandal. Also wir haben auch eine andere, nicht vorhandene Fluchkultur. Bei uns sagt man halt Scheiße und leckt mich am Arsch und das war's. Aber in Spanien ist das Scheiße und leckt mich am Arsch. Halt eher das.
Du kannst mal in meine Insta-DM gucken. Also Fluchkultur ist ja schon durchaus aufgegeben.
Also ich glaube nicht durch Spieler auf dem Spielfeld, das wollte ich sagen.
Ich glaube es geht auch um dieses ins Gesicht rein sagen. Aber ich also bei Korea schon.
Aber generell, also ich habe ein Video gesehen vor ein paar Wochen, da ging es um die um die Bellingham-Sperre, Nichtsperre und seine Aussagen. Da war ein Zusammenschnitt wie Barca mit Messi Neymar und Suarez rumgeflucht hat. Noch und nöcher. Da gab es nie irgendwas. Also Luis Suarez vor allem, auch kein Kind von Traurigkeit. Viele Jahre her, klar, hat da Linienrichter und Schiedsrichter beleidigt in einer Tour. Die standen halt nicht einen Meter neben ihm, sondern halt an der Seitenlinie. Aber da gab es nie irgendwelche Sperrungen oder irgendwas, weil in Spanien das halt einfach dazu gehört. Jetzt kann man sagen, leider, fälschlicherweise. Aber ja, deswegen ist es umso bemerkenswerter, dass er jetzt dann die vier Spiele bekommt, was natürlich richtig ist, weil er hat ganz klar dem Schiedsrichter gesagt, da stand auch nur zwei Metern vor ihm der Schiri. Aber trotzdem im Gesamtkontext schon eine spannende Geschichte.
Ja, also ich will es jetzt nicht noch größer machen, aber man könnte da dann auch eben drüber sprechen. Also gegen Hatespeech und so weiter setzen sich jetzt alle Ligen ein und so weiter. Aber wo fängt es denn an und wo hört es auf? Und ich sage das, das möchte ich vielleicht noch mit dazu sagen. Nicht, dass es hier so rüberkommt, als wäre ich ein Engel. Ich war ein ganz fürchterlicher Scheisspieler, als ich noch Fußball gespielt habe. Ich habe oft gelbe Karten wegen Meckerns gesehen. Weil ich manchmal auch die Regeln ein bisschen besser kannte. Ehrlich gesagt, dass die Schiedsrichter, ich habe immer auf der untersten Niveau gespielt, aber jede der gelben Karten war gerechtfertigt. Ich war einer auch, der immer alles musste raus und ich musste das aber halt dann auch lernen, dass man manchmal, vielleicht auch mal anerkennt, dass es halt der Schiedsrichter...
Was rundet mich jetzt doch, muss ich sagen.
Ja du, ich habe eine Fußballpersonen-Persönlichkeit, ihr könnt ja euch gar nicht vorstellen. Müssen wir uns mal zum Kicken treffen.
Ich bin ja auch immer als Spieler die Tatsache ausgenutzt, dass ich ja selber Schiri war und ich wusste, wann er wohin guckt. Also ich war auch eine fiese Ratte, muss ich sagen, auf dem Platz. Und bin aber immer der, der zum Schiri und neben dem Schiri dann so gesagt hat, wenn ein Mitspieler gemeckert hat, so hey, nee, hat er richtig gesehen. Und dann dachte der Schiri, ah, das ist einer für immer.
Das sind ja alles samt überraschende Bekenntnisse, muss ich sagen.
Wobei, so eine Ratte war ich nicht. Ich hab also bei so Faust und so weiter, ich hab ja immer Libere gespielt, deswegen, ich hatte schon oft quasi die Gegenspieler und die haben ja auch gesehen, wie ich so von der Statur her bin. Das heißt, mit Körperlichkeit konntest du mir schon beikommen. Den Rest hatte ich ganz gut drauf. Ich hab nur reagiert. Also ich ganz oft natürlich irgendwie Schiri schaut nicht und dann kriegst du irgendwie so einen mit oder bei der Ecke steigen sie dir halt mit dem Stollen auf den C und so weiter. Dann hab ich immer gesagt, okay, du machst das genau noch einmal und dann lass ich bei der Grätsche das Knie oben, weil da im Pferdekuss und so weiter und so fort. Das hab ich aber halt dann auch gemacht, ehrlicherweise.
Stille Wasser sind tief, merk ich da an. Also geht mir nicht so.
Alex, kann ich dich belegen?
Alex, respektiert Schiedsrichter.
Ne, tue ich tatsächlich, weil ich selber schon Spiele gepfiffen hab und dann weiß ich, wie schwer das ist. Und ich bin auch Trainer im Amateurbereich aktuell und ich hab noch nie eine gelbe Karte wie ein Meckerns gesehen. Weil wenn ich mich aufreg, mach ich es immer sachlich und erklär ihm immer, was er falsch gemacht hat. Aber immer sachlich. Ne, also ich sag halt dann ja, du musst Geld geben, weil das ist ein klares taktisches Foul. Das machst du natürlich auch laut, aber immer sachlich. Also es ist nie, nie beleidigend oder nie in irgendwie angehend, sondern immer laut, okay, aber sachlich. Und deswegen, ich hab noch nie Geld gegen, wegen Meckern weder als Spieler noch als Trainer gesehen. Von daher.
Stark. Der Anti-Steffen Baumgart, finde ich sehr, sehr gut. Kannst du nicht bitte nächste Union Trainer werden?
Ich fände es übrigens gut, dass dieser Name jetzt zweimal gefallen ist, weil das diese Woche bei uns auch schon Thema war und diese Art und Weise, wie eine vermeintliche kultige Art und Weise mit Menschen umzugehen, da gerade auf die Spitze getrieben wird und wie respektlos da mit JournalistInnen umgegangen wird und auch mit Schiedsrichtern von Seiten des Unionstrenners ist wohnlos.
Was ich übrigens mache, wenn ich sauer auf dem Schiri bin, weil der mich vermeintlich verpfiffen hat, ich verweige den Handschlag nach dem Spiel, dann gehe ich nicht hin und gebe ihm nicht die Hand. Das ist aber auch Quatsch. Also die sind ja wirklich schlecht.
Nach dem Spiel ist es vorbei, Alex.
Nach dem Spiel muss man auch so vom Feld gehen, dass man dann, du musst, also ich hatte auch schon richtig, richtig üble und wir hatten auch die Spiele mit irgendwie Massenschlägerei und einmal hat unser Torhüter mich davor bewahrt, dass ich aus dem Maul gekommen hab. Danke nochmal, Armin. Weil es ist halt einfach der Provinz-Fußball und dann gibt's ja die entsprechenden Gegner und die sogenannten Derbys, bla bla bla. Aber du musst danach vom Feld gehen so, dass du der gegnerischen Mannschaften einen Bierkasten hinstellen kannst und sagen kannst, so der ist für euch. Das nächste Mal.
Da ergibt man sich die Hand.
Das muss schon sein, weil du, ich hatte das auch schon hier bei dem Spiel, wo mir aufs Maul hätte gehauen werden sollen. Da haben die dann abends sind sie dann gekommen, zu SIPT sind irgendwie vor die Turnhalle, weil da war irgendeine Faschingsfeier und haben gesagt, der soll jetzt mal rauskommen, wir regeln das noch. Die wollten das quasi weiterführen und das darf einfach nicht passieren. Weil bei so was passieren auch schlimme Sachen. Einer hat ein Messer dabei. Das ist einfach so. Sorry to say, das heißt irgendwann muss es beendet werden. Und auch mit den Schiedsrichtern. Ich hab den Schiedsrichtern, also ich war auch immer oder oft Kapitän und so weiter, hab eh viel mit denen. Und nach dem Spiel war immer alles in Ordnung. Da hab ich dann auch manchmal gesagt, es tut mir leid, vorhin die Gelbe war richtig. Ich hatte in dem Moment das Gefühl, ich muss das sagen.
Da geh ich hundertprozentig mit nach dem Spiel, aber nach dem Spiel ist halt eine halbe Stunde, Stunde, zwei Stunden nach dem Spiel, wenn sich's beruhigt hat, das Ganze. Aber direkt mit Schlusspfiff ist nicht nach dem Spiel, das ist da immer noch.
Mit Schlusspfiff muss es sicher erledigt haben.
Dann ist es auch Selbstschutz, damit mir nicht der Kontertuchel-Handschlag passiert. Aber nicht falsch verstehen. Es ist nicht so, dass der Schiri auf einen zukommt und dann verweigt meinen Handschlag. Ich geh halt einfach nicht zum Schiedsrichter. Ich würde wirklich so sauer sein sollte, was jetzt nicht häufig passiert. Weil dann geh ich halt einfach nicht zum Schiri, weil wenn ich der Meinung bin, dass mich der Pfiffen, aber Selbstschutz, so kann mir halt auch nichts rausrutschen. So pfeife ich ihm nichts, so sage ich ihm nicht, was ich von seiner Leistung halte.
Dann kriegst du nicht mehr gerettet.
Man trifft die doch so oft wieder. Also ich hatte bei mir den Fall, dass wir dann gespielt haben und bei uns...
Die Schiedsrichter mögen mich, Max.
Da stand der Vettel. Der Vettel ist immer nicht gesprungen. Deswegen, wenn die Gegner das gecheckt haben, dann fingen die Gegentoranwärter, haben die aus 40 Metern ins Eck geschossen und der Vettel hat versucht, hinzulaufen und er ist nicht hingekommen. Und dann ist er auch einmal wieder nicht hingekommen und hat dem gegnerischen Spieler den Ball ins Gesicht geworfen und hat gesagt, du Blöder, ich möchte es nicht weiter zitieren. Und der Schiedsrichter geht hin und ich denke mir so, ja gut, geil, jetzt darf einer von uns Tor. Null Bock. Hab schon überlegt, ob es ich machen muss. Dann gibt er ihm gelb und nach dem Spiel dann, wir verlieren irgendwie keine Ahnung, eins zu acht oder irgendwie so war ganz, ganz düster. Waren auch wieder ein paar Leute, die auf dem Beinfest waren und so weiter. Also auch nicht überraschend. Und nach dem Spiel gehe ich hin zum Schiedsrichter und sage, Schiri, danke, dass sie dem Vettel nur rot gegeben haben, weil das hätte das Ganze hier noch wilder gemacht. Und das war ja sowieso eindeutig. Und da hat der Schiri einfach nur gesagt, ich kenne doch den Vettel. Weil der uns schon fünf Mal gepfiffen hat in den letzten Jahren und der wusste ja, meine Güte ist halt so. Und deswegen musst du den Schiedsrichtern schon die Hand geben, Alex. Du siehst die doch immer wieder auf der Ebene.
Ja, die mögen mich aber drohen.
Ist ein gutes Zeichen auch übrigens.
Ist ein gutes Zeichen, aber wie gesagt eben der Emotion im Affekt und der Schlusspfiff ist ja immer noch, da ist ja gehören noch zu spiel. Das interessiert doch keinen, aber wie gesagt nach dem Spiel, dann eine Stunde später nach dem Duschen, gehe ich immer in die Kabine, gebe in die Hand, dies das. Alles okay, dann kann man auch sachlich darüber reden, aber beim Schlusspfiff selber, wenn ich der Meinung bin, also wenn die Emotionen hochkochen, dann bleibe ich lieber fern, bevor mir was rausrutscht oder bevor ich unsachlich werde, wobei ich ja nicht unsachlich bin, aber so meint ich es eher, viel eher. Aber die sind schon wirklich schlecht, Max.
Ja, ich, Alex, ich weiß das doch. Alex, ich hatte doch auch die Schiedsrichter, die Regeln nicht kannten und so weiter. So war es bei uns auch so, dass dann der Co-Trainer gepfiffen hat. Und ich habe meinen eigenen Co-Trainer mal erklären müssen, wie das mit Upside's läuft mit, da gab es noch nicht ein liberal Play, aber war eine ähnliche Situation und so weiter und so fort. Natürlich, das ist bodenlos. Also Alex, ich gebe dir jetzt meinen, ich gebe dir jetzt meinen Superhero-Move. Was ich gemacht habe, wenn ich wirklich richtig, richtig gepisst war vom Schiedsrichter und wenn ich wirklich am liebsten gesagt hätte, du Drecksack hast uns hier dieses Spiel verpfiffen und jetzt darf ich mir wieder anhören.
Aber sowas mache ich halt nicht.
Dann gehe ich danach hin und habe gesagt, danke, dass sie es uns ermöglicht haben, dass wir heute spielen können. Das war quasi meine passiv-aggressive Art, dass ich nichts Positives zum Schiri zu sagen hatte, weil ohne den Schiedsrichter gibt es kein Spiel. Da bin ich hingegangen, danke, dass sie gekommen sind, ohne sie hätte es kein Spiel gegeben. Da haben sie dann auch mit geguckt wie ein Auto, aber das war quasi mein Alter hast du heute schlecht gepfiffen.
Die neue Regel ist, dass jemand aus den Mannschaften pfeift.
Ja klar, weil es zu wenig Schiedsrichter gibt. Warum gibt es zu wenig Schiedsrichter? Weil ihnen zu selten die Hand geschüttelt wird nach Abpfiff.
Weiß ich nicht. Aber ich musste tatsächlich letztes Jahr einspringen und ein Spiel pfeifen von unserer Mannschaft, obwohl wir Aussatzmannschaft waren, weil der Schiri nicht kam. Und das war, also kurz eine Anekdote, Spielertrainer war auf der anderen Seite, ich bin Spielertrainer bei uns, aber ich spiele sehr selten und der Spielertrainer von denen war Stammspieler und der Schiri kam nicht. Und dann haben wir uns geeinigt, wer pfeift und ich hab immer gelbe Karte, rote Karten, Pfeife hab ich immer einstecken für genau solche Fälle. Und dann hab ich gesagt, ja dann am fairesten, also ich kann gern pfeifen, wenn du das möchtest. Am fairesten wärs natürlich, dass pro Halbzeit einer aus jeder Mannschaft pfeift, dass es nicht heißt, oh der Auswärtstrainer pfeift die Mannschaft. So haben wir uns darauf geeinigt, ich hab die erste Halbzeit gepfeifen und dann zur Halbzeit der andere Spielertrainer wollte aber nicht pfeifen, weil er selbst gespielt hat, dann haben sie von einem auf einem neben platzenden Schiri, von einem anderen Spiel dazu bekommen, die zweite Halbzeit zu pfeifen, was der gemacht hat, also ein echter Schiri. Und nach dem Spiel kam der Gegner zu mir und hat gesagt, Alex du hast besser gepfeifen als der echte Schiri. Kein Witz, weil der wirklich nicht ganz so gut gepfeift hat.
Hat dir jemand die Hand gegeben danach dann vom Gegner?
Jeder hat mir die Hand gegeben, das ist verständlich.
Und wie hat sich das angefühlt?
Ich hätte besser gepfeifen als der echte Schiri.
Ja natürlich, es gibt ganz, ganz schlimme Schiris. Wir hatten immer einen Schiedsrichter, der hat angepfeifen, dann ist er zur Bande gegangen, da wo Schatten war und dann blieb er dort stehen und von dort aus hat er alles entschieden. Abseiß, Faul, Abstoß, Ecke, Einwurf, alles. Glaubte er einfach von da aus.
Aber immerhin, konsequente Spielwirkung.
Ja, und ich mein, das hat natürlich zu Mayhem geführt, immer auf der ihm weit entfernten Seite. Also kannst du dir vorstellen, was da los war bei Freistüßen da und so weiter. Also da hatte ich blutige Zehen danach, der Gegner aber auch ein Pferdekuss mehr. Also klar, aber ja, das ist halt unterstes Niveau. Aber man muss sich ja auch klar machen, dass ohne jetzt hier irgendjemandem in der Runde zu nahe treten zu wollen, aber ich glaube, keiner von uns war wirklich nah am Leistungssport dran.
Und dann ist es schon, oder? Jaja, also näher als wir anderen.
Ja, natürlich. Ich war auch kein schlechter Sportler und so weiter. Aber was ich damit sagen will, ist, dass man sich schon immer wieder klar machen muss, dass das eine Freizeitgestaltung ist, wenn man Fußball spielt. Man liebt diesen Sport, man liebt auch sein Team, man will auch gewinnen. Nichts ist geiler als aufzusteigen oder Meister zu werden und so weiter. Hab ich zum Glück auch mal erlebt. Das ist richtig, richtig toll. Aber es ist ja trotzdem eine Freizeitgestaltung. Wir machen uns doch alle lustig über irgendwelche Modellbauflieger hier. Wie ist das Florian nicht so tief? Dieses berühmte YouTube-Video, wo der Sohn mit Rüdiger, Rüdiger, Rüdiger, das ist natürlich sehr, sehr lustig, weil wir halt denken, ja meine Güte, ist doch nur ein Flugzeug. Aber genau so sind wir doch auf dem Fußballfeld dann auch.
Man muss doch überlegen, in Berlin, ein Kumpel von mir, der ist auch Schiri und pfeift auch relativ tief, also Kreisliga und was der an einer Grundaggressivität ausgesetzt ist, ist schon krass. Also meine Frau und ich fahren auch gern mal hin und gucken, da müssen sie zu, wie er pfeift, so ein bisschen Quarantämpfung hier in Berlin. Und das ist schon krass. Also ich meine, gut, es ist halt Kreisliga. Das heißt, die Linienrichter sind sowieso auch für einen Verein dann gestellt und sind sowieso komplett subjektiv. Aber deswegen finde ich, um da dann mal in Diskussionen anzuschließen, wenn wir immer sagen, der Profifußball ist eine Vorbildfunktion, dann müssen eigentlich auch genau diese Strafen eben auch mal über diese zwei, drei Spiele später hinausgehen. Weil das, in meinen Augen sind sie ja Vorbildfunktion. Das ist ja das, was wir konsumieren jetzt endlich, was sich dann auch widerspiegelt auf diesen Kreislegerplätzen. Und das ist schon also die Stories, die der Kumpel mir da teilweise erzählt von dieser Grundstimmung. Da wundert mich eben nicht, warum nicht so viele mehr pfeifen.
Jetzt geb ihm halt die Hand, Alex.
Ganz umsetzter Verbrechen. Alex, vorher kann ich die Sendung nicht beenden. Wenn du uns jetzt nicht versprichst, dass du das nächste Mal auf den schlechten Schiris die Hand schüttelst und ihn sagst, danke, dass wir uns möglich gemacht haben, dass wir hier spielen. Eine Stunde danach sieht man die doch nicht mehr.
Oder sind die dann noch ein paar Einzelteile? Ich bin ja Coach, ich muss ja da alles aufräumen und dies und das und dem Schiri erklären, wo er hin muss, damit er sein Geld bekommt und ihn die Schiri-Kabine aufmachen, etc. Ich hab ja immer mit denen zu tun, deswegen verstehe ich mich ja so gut mit denen. Aber manchmal wartet man ab, bis man sich wieder gut mit ihnen versteht. Sagen wir es noch so.
Es geht ja auch schon um so Kleinigkeiten. Zum Beispiel gibt es Vereine, die stellen dann auch so ein Obstkorb mal so hin oder so ein bisschen Getränke.
Aber da was gibt es zu nützlich. Ja, genau, da geht es von mir aus. Nein, Obstkorb habe ich noch nie erlebt, aber Wasser biete ich mir immer an, deswegen mögen sie mich ja auch so, aber verpfeifen sie mich immer trotzdem, das ist ja das Tragische.
Vielleicht machen sie das gar nicht mit Absicht, Alex, kann das sein?
Völlig verrückt, ne? Vielleicht hätte das gedacht.
In bestimmten Ligern bekommt man ja auch immer so Verzehrgutschein fürs Restaurant, ich kann mich mal an die Verbandsliga erinnern, da war mir alles gespannt, da war ich junger Linenrichter und da hast du so jeder 15 Euro zum Essen danach. Und dann kam nach dem Spiel, das werde ich nie vergessen, der Präsident von dem Verein in die Kabine und hat gesagt, die Gutscheine nehme ich wieder weg, esst und trinkt so viel ihr wollt, aber bitte kommt nie wieder. Und das haben wir dann gemacht, da wurde dann Vorspeise, Carpaccio, da hatten wir, unser Lehrwart war Shiri, dem war eh alles egal und dann haben wir da gegessen und ich weiß nicht, ob er jemals wieder da war, ich war da nicht noch mal, aber das war lustig.
Also Alex, du hast verschiedene Deeskalationsstufen jetzt mitbekommen, vielleicht einfach ein Big Mac Menü reinstellen und sagen, das war aber das letzte Essen von dir hier und jetzt schleicht dich. Danke, dass sie uns das Spiel ermöglicht haben.
Also in der nächsten Ligatur, wenn die Kombination wieder da ist, ich werde das nicht vergessen, frage ich mal nach, wie sich das verhalten hat.
Ja, aber wirklich. Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, die Hörerinnen und Hörer sind da auch gespannt drauf. So, auch ganz fantastisch, dass wir jetzt einfach in dieser Blitzrunde einfach so beim Tempo geblieben sind. Wollen wir einen ganz schnellen Durchgang noch machen, also von den anderen drei. Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, Daniel, ich glaube du bist dran. Hast du noch ein ganz kurzes Thema? Und dann machen wir aber, dann müssen wir hier leider die Rollenden runterlassen.
Ja, ich noch ganz kurz zum Auflust zwei MVPs. Der eine ist ja die langweilige Lösung, das ist Sam Stein, weil er irgendwie seit jedem Spieltag immer MVP ist. Er hat jetzt schon in 14 Spielen 20 Tore und 4 Vorlagen gemacht, hat das entscheidende 1-0 gegen Almere gemacht, hat seinen Marktwert, im Moment ist er bei 10 Millionen Euro. Der hat in der Saison direkt eine Freistellung gemacht und ist einfach der, der hieft Twente quasi alleine in die internationalen Plätze und der dürfte auch wie schon so oft gesagt nicht mehr allzu lange vermutlich in der RIT UC sein und diese Bereiche haben, aber ich wollte ihn trotzdem erwähnen, weil er an der Erwähnung immer wert ist. Und die andere MVP ist die spannende Lösung, das ist Christopher Peterson von Fortuna Sittard, ist Top-Torschütze von Fortuna, hat schon sieben Tore erzielt, hat jetzt auch das entscheidende 1-0 gemacht gegen Almeno und er hat eigentlich auch großen Anteil daran, dass Fortuna da ist, wo sie aktuell sind. Die sind auf Platz 8, haben 32 Punkte. Das ist für Fortuna sehr formidabel und das wäre aktuell der Playoff-Platz für die Conference League, den sie aktuell in der haben und ist mit seinen 30 Jahren auch so eine Art Lieder, auch in der Kabine. Und man kennt ihn vielleicht noch aus unserer Zeiten, wo er so vorwahrt. Und überlebt die Verantwortung, macht auch die Elfmeter und genau, das sind so meine beiden MVP's noch schnell.
Sehr, sehr schön. Mario, wen hast du noch oder was hast du noch auf dem Zettel?
Ich hab noch eine viel gute Story, die ist aber jetzt tatsächlich auch schon eine Woche her, also wem sie noch nicht irgendwie als Real durch den Algorithmus, durch einen italienischen Algorithmus bei Instagram reingespült worden ist. Jonathan Klinsmann spielt jetzt in der Serie B bei Cezena. Und da gab es letztens kurz vor Schluss einen Elfmeter gegen Cezena. Und dann hat er sich umgedreht beim Stand von 0 zu 0 und hat den Balljungen gefragt, wo der Schütze hinschießt. Und dann hat der Balljunge, der Ivan, gesagt rechts. Und dann ist Jonathan Klinsmann nach rechts gesprungen, hat den Ball gehalten. Cezena hat das Spiel sogar noch gewonnen. Danach gab es ein Trikot und eine Umarmung von Jonathan Klinsmann für Ivan. Und ja, das fand ich ganz herzerwärmend.
Sehr, sehr gut. Wahrscheinlich fängt es jetzt anders, die Gegner die Balljungen briben und bestechen und sagen, hier sag ihm rechts, dann kriegst du von mir das Trikot. Und dann wird es interessant, was Ivan macht. Aber gut. Uli, wir werden glaube ich jetzt nicht mehr über United und das neue Stadion und alles drumherum sprechen, denn das ist noch mal eine halbe Stunde. Ähnlich emotional vielleicht. Hast du noch was Kleines?
Ja, also wahrscheinlich können wir noch mal kurz nach, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das gemacht haben. Crystal Palace wäre vielleicht ein kurzes Thema, weil es relativ schnell erklärt ist. Erste acht Spiele gar nicht gewonnen. Große Kritik an Oliver Glasner haben wir, glaube ich, hier mal besprochen, wenn ich mich recht entzanne. Und jetzt aber im Verlauf der Saison sich pöa pöa gesteigert. Jetzt sind es sieben Siege in zehn Spielen und andauernde Gespräche über die Vertragsverlängerung. Also Crystal Palace hat Oliver Glasner recht klar signalisiert, dass sie mit ihm gerne weitermachen wollen. Glasner selbst soll wohl, also zumindest in den Gesprächen sein, ich weiß nicht, ob er wirklich hundertprozentig da dahinter steht, aber habe ganz oft nachgefragt, auch bei ihm, wie seine Einschätzung geht in der Saison, warum das nicht vernünftig losging. Die Einschätzung, die hat sehr sinnvoll geklungen, wenn er sie gemacht hat, nämlich fehlende Fitness. Ganz viele Spieler, die spät dazugekommen sind, zu ganz unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten noch dazu, was die Trainingssteuerung schwierig gemacht hat. Das heißt, er hat unterm Strich gesagt, die sind alle nicht fit hier, hat es auch ein bisschen ausgeweitet. Ich weiß aber nicht, wie viel davon in die Öffentlichkeit gehört und wie viel nicht. Ist jetzt auch wahrscheinlich für die Kürze irrelevant. Und das letzte Mal, als ich mit ihm gesprochen habe, hat er gesagt, jetzt habe ich die Mannschaft da, wo ich will, sonst wiehe da sie gewinnen. Es war aber noch in der Zeit, als es gar nicht gut lief für ihn. Ich sag das, man wirft ihm oder warf ihm zwischenzeitlich, das kennt man glaube ich auch noch aus Frankfurt, immer mal wieder vor, dass er schon immer die Ausreden parat hatte. Zu dem Zeitpunkt hatten sie wieder eine Negativ-Serie nicht gewonnen. Dann haben sie gesagt, jetzt gibt es keine Ausreden, auch nicht für die Truppe, die sind fit, die müssen jetzt liefern. Und seither sind sieben in zehn. Und Crystal Palace ist wieder da, wo sie letzte Saison aufgehört haben, nämlich in Schlagdistanzen für gewisse Dinge. Gibt ja ganz wilde und grude Dinge, dass theoretisch sogar ich glaube sieben Champions-Signa aus England kommen könnten und dann entsprechend glaube ich bis zu elf Europapokal teilnehmen. Da wäre jetzt ein Region.
Oh Mann ey. Ja, Entschuldigung. Also ich hatte das ja natürlich schon mal gelesen, damals schon als die Reform kam, aber der Gedanke ist einfach ein bisschen wild. Sehr schön. Ja, dann haben wir jetzt nämlich auch Oliver Glasen das Rolle dann noch ein bisschen eingeordnet. Maxence Lacroix hatten wir ja auch schon in der letzten Folge erwähnt. Ihr Vier, das hat große Freude gemacht. Das war ja fast schon psychoanalytisch, was wir hier in Teilen abgeliefert haben. Und eigentlich müssten wir fast mal die die Sendung machen, wo wir nur von unseren eigenen Fußballerlebnissen erzählen. Ich habe den Eindruck, da liegt Gold begraben und wo hast du denn, willst du das sagen? Wo ich gespielt habe? Nein, nein, nein. Ich komme ja aus Mittel beziehungsweise Unterfranken. Also der SV Unteralten Bernheim war meine erste Station. Ihr alle werdet jetzt aufhauchen wahrscheinlich. Die haben die haben damals erstmal die Jugendabteilung gründen müssen und meiner Mutter wurde nichts davon erzählt, weil die alle davon ausgegangen sind, die verbietet das bestimmt, dass ich mitspielen darf, was totaler Quatsch war. Aber naja Frauenbild auf Dörfern halt. Erste Spiel 1 zu 16 verloren, das zweite Spiel. Aber ich habe ratet, wer für die 1 gesorgt hat. Your boy. Der ganze, der ganze Sportplatz war voll, alle Eltern waren da und die haben gejubelt ohne Ende. Und ich weiß noch genau, wie mich so ein gegnerischer Spieler anguckt, als ich so zurück trabe, so langsam, natürlich auch so in die Menge grüßend Richtung. Und dann guckt er mich an und sagt so, seid ihr alle bescheuert? Weiß was 1 zu 16. Zweites Spiel dann 0 zu 36 gegen Emskirchen. Ich hab immer noch, hab immer noch einen Hass gegen Emskirchen. Wir hatten fünf verschiedene Torhüter, weil wir damals die... Weil wir hatten doch nicht, wir hatten noch nicht fix ausgemacht, wer Torhüter ist. Ich war zwischendurch auch drin. Ich hab nur zwei Gegentore kassiert. Aber der Trainer hat gesagt, nee, wir brauchen dich draußen, weil du bist der Einzige, der einen Schuss hat, der weit genug geht, dass du mal den Ball nicht gegen die Schälfte schießen kannst. Dann haben wir kurz Ruhe. Und dann, so wurde ich zum Libero. Und dann später beim SV Magdeheim. Also, do your Google Work. Jetzt könnt ihr es nachsuchen. Aber soweit ich weiß, sind die Statistiken von denen nicht so gut gepflegt. Ja. So. Tribüngespräch incoming zu unseren Fußballgeschichten. Vielen, vielen Dank euch vier. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch lieben Hörern und Hörern für euren Support. Ganz wichtig. Registriert euch bitte als Supporter erinnern, wenn ihr Daueraufträge habt. Denn die müssen geändert werden. Und in der Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Oliver Levin, bei Friedrich, bei Domaniac und bei Magda Lehner. Und ansonsten gilt natürlich, wenn ihr Feedback habt, mitmachen.rasen.de und abonniert doch bitte auch die anderen Formate. Wir sprechen über die Bundesliga der Männer, über die Bundesliga der Frauen, über das Tribüngespräch.
Ihr Assis.
Und übers Nationalteam. Und wir alle haben gerade Alex die Hand geschüttelt.
Eine Handshake zum Abschied.
Denn jetzt sind alle bösen Gedanken, die sind genau weg und zwar jetzt. Macht's gut. Tschau.
Der Rasenton lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.